la sphère ses textes souvient rebondi
selon des enregistrements récemment
versé au dossier d' enquêtes judiciaires
le père de famille a crié cette fois
j'étouffe avant de perdre connaissance
le 3 janvier 2020 il décédera deux jours
plus tard des suites d'une fracture du
larynx occasionnés par son
immobilisation par une clé
d'étranglement et par un placage
ventrale
depuis le début la famille de cédric
joue via crient à la bavure policière
il se trouve que ces enregistrements que
se sont procurés le monde et mediapart
vont peser dans l' enquête judiciaire
ils contredisent les propos des quatre
policiers qui avaient procédé à sept
interpellations
les avocats de la famille souvient
aujourd'hui ont tenu une conférence de
presse je vous propose de les écouter ce
qui a conduit à la mort de cédric joue
via c'est un enchaînement inexorable
c'est-à-dire ce chantage à l outrage qui
est provoquée à chaque fois que les
personnes sont contrôlées les
fonctionnaires de police quand il
contrôle des gens savent qu'ils ont une
dissymétrie et qu'ils peuvent les
poursuivre pour outrage et donc il ya
une provocation à l'outragé face à un
homme et de rien a rappelé tragiquement
qui dit je ne peux plus respirer cette
fois d'autres dont les jambes et frappe
le macadam pour dire qu'il est pas loin
d'agonie les policiers de façon tout à
fait insensé font l'inversé de ce qu'on
va faire c'est à dire s'arrêter des
experts de l'institut de recherche
criminelle de la gendarmerie nationale
ont donc analysé 13 vidéos dont celle de
cédric joue via et de la policière
présente sur les lieux
il dispose également d'un enregistrement
sonore de 12 minutes
il a été effectué grâce à un micro qui
se trouvait dans le casque de cédric
joue via les experts ont rendu un
rapport le 21 avril
il déclare je cite l'échangé
relativement correcte même si nous
pouvons ressentir une forme de défiance
et de provocation dans les paroles de la
personne contrôlée
selon l' enquête de l'igpn est les
quatre policiers auraient déclaré que
cédric joue via ses montées
irrespectueux agressif et menaçant
et ce sont ces outrages qui aurait mené
à l'interpellation
or à l'écouté des enregistrements où se
rend compte que cédric joue via a bien
adopté un ton provocateur mais les
insultes en question son guignol clowns
ou encore pauvre type
nulle trace d'agressivité ni de menaces
dans ses propos en revanche un des
policiers a eu un commentaires
dégradants
il a dit aux livreurs tu veux pas que je
mettre à quatre pattes et que je te je
vous laisse imaginer la vulgarité des
propos tenus
les quatre policiers impliqués dans
l'interpellation de cédric joue via ont
été entendus le 17 juin à la demande du
juge d'instruction entendu en garde à
vue c'est une procédure rare mais ils
n'ont pas été suspendu et leur mise en
examen ne reste qu'une éventualité
les avocats de la famille ont en tout
cas déposé une plainte avec constitution
de partie civile pour violence
volontaire d'une personne dépositaire de
l'autorité publique
les avocats de la famille demande en
outre à christophe castaner d'interdire
le placage ventrale est la clé
d'étranglement des techniques décriés
pour leur dangerosité potentielle